et pour en parler nous sommes avec eric
tricot infirmier anesthésiste à
l'hôpital henri mondor membres du
syndicat sud-santé bonsoir electrico
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france vous en tout cas votre syndic a
claqué la porte du ségur de la santé
pour quelle raison parce que c'est une
mascarade
si les puits moins qu'une mascarade
allez on a l'impression qu'ils
découvrent les revendications alors ces
revendications ont été portés temps
quand le collectif inter urgence au
départ et après aussi par des syndicats
dont le syndicat sud-santé que je
représente
mais aussi par le collectif inter
hospitalier et là c'est une mascarade
parce que pourquoi pas parce que
simplement on a l'impression qu'ils sont
en train de jouer la montre joue le
temps on arrive on est début juin on
sait très bien que derrière ça va être
juillet-août savate et grandes vacances
il espère que la pression va retomber
parce que la paix y aura d'autres
objectifs tant pour les personnels parce
qu'on va redevenir des papas des mamans
et qu'il faudra emmener les enfants à
l'école voilà c'est ni plus ni moins
qu'une stratégie détestable à les
limites humiliante parce que c'est
vraiment faire promettre de d comment je
pourrais dire des objectifs qui ne
seront jamais tenues on le voit bien de
façon on va de de promesses en promesses
qui ne sont pas tenues et de désillusion
en désillusion clicquot qu'est ce qui
vous fait dire ça sur quelles
revendications il y avait vraiment eu un
point de désaccord trouve aux phases se
maudire ces fichus plus de dialogue
possible on s'en va parce que simplement
madame totale là dit elle n'a aucune
marge de manoeuvre
elle est simplement là à la rigueur je
sais pas peut-être médiatrice ne sais
pas du tout et j'ai du mal à définir son
rôle a vraiment en toute honnêteté
donc elle n'a pas de marge de manoeuvre
elle écoute les doléances l écoutent les
revendications mais ces revendications
on les connaît tout le monde et connaît
tous les citoyens et les concitoyens de
france nous ont vus
à la manoeuvre avec cette pandémie et
ils nous ont épaulés ils nous ont
soutenus ils ont compris que l'hôpital
public était en grande difficulté
mais malgré toutes ces difficultés
politiques parce que ce sont ni plus ni
moins que des décisions politiques qui
ont mis l'hôpital public sur le sera en
difficulté comme cela on est à
décloisonner le complètement tous les
corps de métier on a fait face à la
pandémie
voilà c'est ce simplement des
revendications elles sont pas monstrueux
ses revendications et ses 300 ans pour
l'instant de rattrapage c'est avoir une
gauche né pourra avoir une embauche de
personnel il faut avoir des salaires
qu'ils puissent être attractif et après
il faut être fidélisant au niveau de ses
personnels et pour être fidélisant il ya
plusieurs il ya plusieurs lignes de
conduite à avoir ne serait-ce que les
plans de formation enfin blaye
on a des idées on les a on les a donnés
en ça fait des êtres des mois qu'on ne
peut pas dire des années qu'on l'ait
qu'on les a développés on les à achille
et quand il découvre là il découvre
alors il peut faire son mea culpa le
président macron il peut
moi je sais pas non je suis honnêtement
je suis pourquoi pardonnez moi pourquoi
continuer ce ségur de la santé
6e vous nous dites voilà nicole notât
n'a aucune marge de manoeuvre à vous
comprendre c'est déjà plié alors déjà
qu'est ce qu'on vous propose à ce que
déjà vous le savez déjà donc c'est plus
du tout ce qu'on va proposer nous
traquons on sait ce qu'on veut aller
chercher ça c'est une certitude
jusqu'à encore quelques mois on était
dernier de cordée et on l'était dégueu
le ont été habillées en guenilles en
tout cas pour faire face à la pandémie
on est devenus les premiers de cordée
sous la pression populaire et la
pression française parce qu'on a été mis
en avant
on n'a jamais demandé à être en guerre
moi je ne suis pas en guerre je suis un
personnel soignant
je combats effectivement une maladie
mais on me donne les moyens là on nous a
absolument pas donné les moyens pour
faire face à cette pandémie et
maintenant ils voudraient enfin on a
l'impression que ce gouvernement se
rachète une conduite
si ni plus ni moins qu'un plan comme on
est dans un plan d'eau
il essaye de bien mener sauf que nous on
a levé le lièvre
je pense qu'il ya d'autres syndicats qui
vont le lever voilà pourquoi par exemple
refusé que les représentants des
collectifs quand un terreau l'urgence
que tant interne hospitalier que tant
les collectifs des ibode le collectif
des infirmiers anesthésistes donc les
ibos et des infirmières de bloc
opératoire mais d'autres collectifs
pourquoi les refuser à une table de deux
revendications et doléances qui portent
tous et toutes les mêmes revendications
rachid est selon ses ces diplômés ces
décrets de compétences mais n'empêche
que pour l'instant ces deux
revendications qui sont portées par les
personnels soignants ce gouvernement
joue la monde joue le la commune le plan
de com exactement et joua il joue
l'amour on sait que dans trois semaines
c'est juillet août
les gens vont partir en vacances parce
que croyez moi pour l'avoir vécu aussi
en tant que soignant on est épuisé ça a
été deux mois et demi pour trois mois
pour certains secteurs très chronophage
anxiogène avec des conséquences
physiques mais aussi psychologiques pour
les soignants on sait qu'on a besoin de
jours on sait qu'on aura besoin de
vacances
il jouait la montre moi c'est ni plus ni
moins qu' une visibilité que l'on a de 7
mètres de cette mascarade annonce de la
journée 14 une cérémonie pour vous
rendre hommage
on imagine que je façonne amer dans vos
oreilles comme le 14 14 juillet aussi
descendre les champs 90 et dont on sait
où on est on a pas 50 objectifs trop
d'interdits on dit toujours prône
interdit depuis les interdits nous on a
pas 50 objectifs on l'a on en a des tout
simple pour l'instant on est sur des
ressorts certains établissements ils ont
matérialisé certes avec des jeudis de la
colère donne scellé mardi nous soit
henri mondor à créteil
ça a été de lundi on l'a fait
aujourd'hui parce qu'effectivement lundi
là c'était férié donc on s'est adapté
parce que les personnels ont besoin
d'exprimer cette colère et cette
humiliation parce qu'il ya eu des
moments où ça a été très très dur où on
est descendu de la revue porter nos
revendications je vous rappelle quand
même que les
le gouvernement avait donné les ordres
aux forces de l'ordre de nous taper
dessus
donc on a été oubliés on a été bafouée
on a été tapée on a été mal gaz et on a
un objectif là qui est sûr qu'ils aient
un objectif national qui est le 16 juin
on sait qu'on est dans un d'urgence
sanitaire on sait que c'est interdit on
sait que ben on va faire la
d'éblouissants civile tels que certains
grands noms est certes un grand préfet
l'ont fait pendant la guerre sous
l'occupation allemande
vous allez me dire que je fais un
parallèle qui est peut-être un petit peu
simple et un peu trop rapide
n'empêche qu'on fera de la désobéissance
civique et le sèche moins on sera dans
la rue on est en train d'en discuter
pour savoir où croyez moi on trouvera un
lieu où peut-être différents lieux et
les multiples lieux on ne sait pas
encore mais le 16 juin les personnels
soignants et les personnels surtout
hospitaliers seront dans la rue et on
appelle massivement tous les usagers et
tous les concitoyens citoyens qui nous
ont soutenus et croyez-moi ça nous a
fait chaud d'avoir des applaudissements
à 20 heures on les appelle à venir nous
soutenir parce que notre combat
effectivement site pour l'hôpital public
mais on se bat aussi est notre combat
c'est aussi pour prodiguer des soins de
qualité aux usagers qui en ont besoin le
service public
il a eu peur et ronda ses missions la
merci donc les soignants qui appellent à
la grève nationale le 16 juin et vous y
serez rick tricot merci d'avoir été en
direct sur rt france